Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
There were a bunch of Star Wars announcements
this week.
Ahsoka Season two,
The Mandalorian. Season four Details.
Dave Filoni
basically just became the Kevin value of all Star Wars.
Like he just took control of all of Star Wars,
which a lot of us assumed had either already happened
or would happen pretty soon.
So we'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I'll be doing.
Mandalorian Season four Videos. Ahsoka Season two.
As we get more details in, we have the Skeleton
Crew series, which is a Mandalorian spinoff
that'll be happening early next year to I will do
episode videos for everything they wind up releasing.
Don't worry,
we'll get more trailers for that pretty soon.
starting with the big stuff first, Dave Filoni
basically taking over all of Star Wars.
What just happened is that Dave Filoni
that is big interview for Ahsoka season
two, like right after the Ahsoka finale.
But it sounds like they held the interview
till after the strikes had finished
because there were a bunch of announcements
that Lucasfilm was sitting on
in a bunch of projects that were waiting
to actually get started till after the strikes.
So they just wait
until after the strikes to release the interview
where he was talking about all these upcoming projects.
One of the terms we use is, you know, the war
between the New Republic and the Remnant empire.
So we're going to see, you know, you need a conflict.
And I'm, you know, just kind of looking
at a lot of the things that were written over the years
in various expanding universe projects,
trying not just to look at what John and I did,
but we're looking at what was done
kind of historically in the time period is a guide,
I think, for,
you know, generations of Star Wars fans
before the era of, you know, episode 79
that was what we saw as we turn to the Jedi era,
when you're talking about story and characters,
I think in the expanding universe.
So there is a treasure of things to to draw from,
not just within our own series,
but in the bigger galaxy.
but basically, after Ahsoka season one finished,
they had already soft greenlit Ahsoka season two.
Dave Filoni had been working on the scripts for season
two for a while, but they still needed a lot of work.
Then the strikes happened,
so they had to pause all development for a while.
same thing with The Mandalorian Season four,
like they couldn't actually start
filming season four until after
the strikes are finished, which they are now.
Thankfully. ba.
Dave Filoni explained that before this year
what used to happen
is that he served as sort of like a creative director
role behind the scenes with all Star Wars
projects, like all the movies in the TV shows,
but they'd only bring him in for his creative
input to try and fix things or make things better
after the projects had already gotten started.
really good example of that is the Star Wars
sequel trilogy of Movies Force Awakens,
The Last Jedi, Rise of Skywalker,
even stuff like Rogue One, the Han Solo movie.
he's been a co-creator and a Co-Showrunner
on The Mandalorian with Jon Favreau and all the
animated shows he's been showrunning the Ahsoka
series by himself without Jon Favreau's help.
So some of that stuff he was working on from day one,
like some of the stuff he helped develop himself
but all the other shows like Andor Obi-Wan Kenobi,
the movies,
they'd bring him in later in the process and he try
and help them make the movies better fix problems.
Same thing with the TV shows
So a lot of times there were issues
that he couldn't really address
because they were too far along in the process.
Like when it came to the sequel trilogy of movies,
they had already laid so much track
and there was so much work that already been done do.
They could only do so much to make the movies
better after the fact.
what he himself basically just revealed, though,
is that he kind of
become like the Kevin Feige of Star Wars
pretty recently.
It sounds like it happened earlier this year
and they just waited to announce it.
but it was basically him getting a big promotion,
so to speak, and getting creative control
over all Star Wars, everything,
all the movies, the TV shows, publishing everything.
so whereas they'd only bring him in to get his input
after stuff was up and running already.
Now anybody that wants to make new Star Wars
movies, TV shows,
anything has to pitch him the idea first
before they actually get started making it.
So as part of this larger interview
about the future of all Star Wars this past year,
he said that he's there in the room
basically deciding on what the future
of Star Wars is actually going to look like,
whereas before that wasn't the case.
Mostly he's talking about the movies and the TV shows.
so like the the Last Star Wars celebration
and they announced a bunch of upcoming Star Wars
movies taking place all across the timeline.
Dave Filoni is basically there in the room
deciding what those movies
are actually going to be, what they're going to look
like as the directors are hired and brought on board.
this is basically them
finally addressing one of the major
criticisms of the sequel trilogy of movies
like the past ten years.
They got started without any real clear
vision on the entire story.
Like any real creative control, there's
no actual Kevin Foggy type of person in the room
having that kind of control over the movies
that has the creative vision to actually pull that off.
for example,
Kathleen Kennedy is really more of like an overseer,
kind of like a glorified accountant signing
all the checks she's had creative input before,
but for the most part,
usually what they've done in the past, particularly
with the movies, is, is they'll hire directors
to come on in writers and just let those directors
do basically whatever they want to do.
but this big upgrade that they gave to Dave
Filoni kind of just happened
at DC with James Gunn
taking over all movies and DC shows.
He's basically doing the same thing
that Dave Filoni is doing now.
It's Star Wars. in just like James Gunn.
Dave Filoni is also supposed to be directing the Thrawn
movie, like James Gunn is directing Superman Legacy,
but he's also creatively overseeing all movies
and TV shows.
Same thing with Ahsoka Season two, like Dave Filoni
will also be the showrunner for Ahsoka Season two.
You know, they'll be Co-Showrunner on The Mandalorian.
Here's where we get to Ahsoka Season
two in The Mandalorian, Season four.
So as part of this big preview of the future Star Wars,
Dave Filoni confirmed that during Ahsoka season two,
They did plan to continue the Baylan Skoll storyline,
which a lot of us believe they would.
There was such a big teaser.
At the end of the finale he addressed Ray Stephenson's
passing May he rest in peace
told a couple funny stories about them,
talking about the character behind the scenes,
like there was so much story
that they were setting up with his character.
He did say that they intended on paying that off.
Now, he didn't say explicitly
that they were going to recast the character,
only that they would pay the story off.
but I think a lot of us reading between the lines would
not be surprised if they did recast the character.
Basically, the last time we saw him
at the end of the finale, he was standing on the statue
of the more disguised the father,
the son, the daughter with him staring at the beacon
in the distant mountain that the father was pointing
at, basically trying to enter
what looked like the mortis realm, possibly
becoming more to Scott or just harness their power
and like you said, end all war all over the universe
In order to do something like that, that would be like
a final solution for the entire universe.
Like you either have to kill a ton of people
or make some massive, massive charge,
which would require power on the level of the mortals
gods.
That's why you're seeing all this fan
art of Anika Skywalker to soak up in the place
that the mortals got here.
Like they are becoming new versions
of the modernist gods.
I did a bunch of separate videos about that,
so I'll link them below in the description.
basically Anakin Skywalker sort of taking the role
that the mortise gods used to serve,
kind of becoming a Mortis guy, so to speak.
But basically what the father told him
during the Clone Wars is that he was destined
to essentially take their role in the universe. it.
That was meant to be the full actual
fulfillment of the prophecy.
Not so much balancing the Jedi order,
which most people believe,
but in a much more cosmic way,
balanced everything in the entire universe.
He also did say that the development of this
pretty galaxy, them introducing
this other galaxy was a big, big long play
in the movies that they'll eventually pay off.
Like it wasn't just meant to be this one side off thing
in this ahsoka's season, one.
I think that was mostly him
also talking about the Knight Sisters
and bringing them back in the Star Wars universe.
the ancient witch kingdom of the death.
Mary going to need like two or three spinoff TV shows
just about them.
Dave Filoni also addressed that ending scene teaser
with Anakin Skywalker and Ahsoka.
He said the intention was for Akin to be viewing Ahsoka
after all they'd been through this season
recently withdrawn inside the world between worlds
like he was also the same Anakin
that gave Ahsoka her final lesson, confirming that
like it wasn't two different versions of Anakin,
and he was smiling here because he was happy to see
that Ahsoka had become wiser through her experience
and would be a much better master to her Padawan
Sabine Wren.
and this was not the last we had seen of.
Anakin Skywalker
now it sounds like based on the way
that they're plotting things out, is it Ahsoka Season
two is going to fall before the Thrawn movie in
They'll use more time during that descent
through on the ninth sister
storyline inside the main galaxy, but
also using some of the Mandalorian season
four for that too.
so here's where we jump to The Mandalorian Season four.
A lot of the plot of season
four is supposedly going to revolve around
Mando and Grogu going around looking for Thrawn,
the other Imperial Remnant forces.
Now that Ezra Bridger has told the New Republic
about what's happened.
so The Mandalorian season four
is basically taking all that story
they set up at the end of Ahsoka season
one and running with it like that.
Basically the next part of the story
as we head towards a Thrawn movie in the whole idea
at the end of the Mandalorian season
three in this scene here was meant to be
Mando taking a job doing mercenary work
for the New Republic specifically,
and he be hunting the imperial remnant
around the outer rim.
So it's more of like a hunter seeker
bounty hunter type of season,
kind of like season one,
but specifically targeting Imperials.
Katie Sackhoff talking about Bo-Katan
The other Mandalorians also said that her character
was not going to be taking over the show
or anything like that, so that means there won't be
that much of the mandalorians on the Mandalore planet,
but probably just like a little bit
to check in with them.
There was so much of them during season
three. People are like, What's going on?
Is she going to take over the TV show?
according to Katee Sackhoff, that is not the case.
The show is still going to be just about din
djarin in Grogu. You.
but because Pedro Pascal has like three
or four other movies now that he's also working on
in a couple other TV shows that basically confirms
that he is not going to be taking the helmet off
during season four, probably not going to take it off
until the Thrawn movie winds up happening.
That's basically the way they did season three.
So just imagine the same type of performance that he
had during season three just a voiceover performance.
they won't actually start filming season four
until early next year, but it's basically ready to go.
Like Jon
Favreau had the scripts ready to go a while ago.
I do not think they're going to finish special effects
in time for a December release, though,
so they might try to release season four in early 2025,
around the same time that they released Season three.
that means that they hustle
they might be able to get a circa season two out
by the end of 2025 around the time
they're trying to release that next Star Wars movie.
But because the strikes delayed everything
almost like a whole year,
they might not release the next Star Wars movie,
whatever that winds up being until 2026.
but basically this Dave Filoni interview
confirmed that the next Star Wars
movie will be the one that's set in the future
after the events
of the Rise of Skywalker,
the Thrawn movie would happen like the year after that.
so say your clocks based on when that next Star Wars
sequel movie winds up
happening the next big TV show
that's going to be happening will be Skeleton Crew.
That could be coming out sometime early 2024,
maybe by the spring.
So we should get a trailer for that pretty soon.
there was a much bigger trailer
for that earlier last year.
I've already done a video for it,
so I'll link it down to the description below.
And the Star Wars acolyte series,
which are probably going to be releasing it sometime
late next year to, Whenever they wind up announcing,
of course, they'll do videos for it.
So no worries.
click Here for my other Mandalorian Season four teaser
video and learn what's going on with Callixtus
in live action and click here for that Star Wars
acolyte trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!